Kellyanne Conway counselor to President
Trump joins me now live boy there's a
lot of news to get to today and the
White House is right in the middle of it
let's start with where we are with this
stimulus bill and kind of where you
think it needs shoring up because seeing
those unemployment numbers now Kellyanne
maybe we'll need more Harris thanks for
having me and I just left a call that
the President and Vice President are
having with our nation's governors I
came off that call to come out here and
I will tell you on that call secretary
minuchin reported to the governor's
precisely what is in this stimulus
package for them and he reviewed the
fact that we have over 100 billion
dollars in direct support to our
hospitals our first responders our
health care workers in addition about 27
billion dollars for life-saving vaccines
and other and replenishing our critical
supply chain he also was talking about
the 370 billion plus for small business
owners and I just want to read this to
you because it's pretty impressive to
hear how two months worth of your
employees salaries so long as you keep
those employees you can't just kick them
off the payroll and fire people and use
the money for other purposes so there
are guarantees in there it's also meant
to help with child care needs of those
health care workers first responders
sanitation workers who can't not show up
to work who can't telework Harris we
need them on the front lines and god
bless each and every one of them so you
want to help them with the child care
needs as well Amy yeah today you had
very tough unemployment numbers these
are shocking but not surprising
everybody warned us that it would be
this bad and I think extraordinary
unprecedented times yield unprecedented
numbers like this but it also yields a
unprecedented measures like this
stimulus let me just give you a good
news we have creating jobs because I
want the audience forgive me and I know
there's a little bit of delay but we
work together on this what's on the
screen for our viewers right now we're
going to hit that number so people can
see what it is
so the jobless claims are we hit a
record sore past a record three point
twenty eight million up from two hundred
eighty two thousand the previous week
and of course we've been in record
territory on how low it's been recently
so that is a change but I just
want to jump in there and say this it
also shattered the Great Recession of
2008 peak of 665,000 and the all-time
high peak of 695 thousand in a week set
back in October of 82 I understand the
amount that's in there now some
governor's are saying in their states
the money for them won't be enough but
when you see these numbers you want
people to keep people on the payroll
this may not be enough is there a phase
for coming there very well could be
actually the president just broached
that in response to a very specific
question he got from one of the state
leaders and I'm sure the White House
will put out a readout this is the third
of three in very quick succession
packages coming out in the bicameral
bipartisan way if this reaches the
President's desk tomorrow Harris's we
expect it will he will sign it and then
the implementation begins secretary
minuchin is said within the next three
weeks people can see that direct deposit
or checks if you don't have direct
deposit twelve hundred dollars per
person for a family of four with two
school-age children that's thirty four
hundred dollars we recognize that as
this goes on that may not be enough but
we stand ready to continue giving that
relief to American workers individuals
and industries that are in a specific
distress and let me say this is really
just a continuation of the pro American
worker agenda that the president has put
forward from the beginning and we want
to continue to make sure that people
know this this is this is a medical
crisis not a financial crisis first and
foremost why the president says we're
gonna turn back on the American economy
but after we follow the facts and the
data but Harris I just didn't want to
quickly just work with you of the places
that are I'm sorry your Joe must be in
the way because I want I want to I want
a segue from what you said because you
set this up perfectly you said this is a
medical emergency and boy I got to tell
you Kellyanne it's looking pretty dire
in some parts of the country not our
heart hospitals across America are
facing a crisis with shortages of
equipment and protective gear we're
hearing directly from the people on the
front lines so no politics here we're
talking with those people at the
hospitals 13 patients at a New York City
Hospital have died of coronavirus at one
Hospital Kellyanne in one day and all of
the city's 1,800 intensive
air-beds reportedly expected to be full
by tomorrow
by Friday headed into the weekend we had
a doctor on last hour
dr. Meharry on outnumbered Kellyanne who
said that they are splitting ventilators
I'm gonna drill down with doctors later
this hour to see what that means and can
they be repurposed and what that does
with such high contagion but all of this
speaks to what you were talking about
this is a medical emergency how does the
president meet that and also face the
headwind of what's coming in the economy
we've been working around the clock and
when I say we beginning with the
president the vice-president the task
force obviously FEMA is very heavily
involved now running the response as
FEMA does and I just heard administrator
Pete Gaynor tell the nation's governors
and mayors and territory and tribal
leaders that FEMA is there but first
your local counties and cities have to
go to the state first because we're
dealing with the states and then you go
to your ten FEMA regional administrators
to answer your questions they are
surging supplies in fact he made clear
that we are acquiring supplies overseas
we're acquiring acquiring supplies from
state to state and that we do want our
anesthesiologist our critical care
medicine our clinics every one of
hospitals to take account of maybe what
they do have so we can have a better
piece of information better data about
what exists in the last two days alone
4400 ventilators have been sent by FEMA
to the state of New York
we know that the governor there said he
needs more and more as to other states
we are trying to go to the places most
in need where we see those clusters that
are there and growing I do think it's
very disappointing that the mayor of New
York City himself was running the subway
on March 5th and telling people to go
and I want to stop second politics well
it's not politics it's that we have a
very dire situation in New York City
that is not politics I think it was
politics to say go out we do have a dire
situation we did notice our situation
tonight but that's why this that look I
think this unanimously passed in the
Senate is the point it's five martes and
frankly it's nonpartisan Harris we
haven't talked about politics here in a
very long time at the White House this
is nonpartisan people are suffering
which is why
of three this is the third of three
economic relief packages that this
president is signing to give that Direct
Relief and I'm very happy that the
Congress in the Senate have come
together in the bipartisan bipartisan
bicameral way to do what in addition to
everything else this package over 100
billion dollars indirectly leave to
those hospitals and health care workers
they are the heroes they're out in the
frontline and they can't tell the work
they can't take a day off they're there
over time we want to make sure hundred
out there that they are that they've got
the personal protective equipment I was
happy to see what more believes I should
say to see the governor of New York
today say in his press conference that
they have PPE immediate needs they have
it for the immediate term so as again we
take those inventories and we surge our
supplies we are working overtime to do
that all right real quickly is there a
discussion in the White House today with
the president about that Easter date as
we now haven't even doctors are saying
haven't yet hit the apex in some of
these hard-hit areas by kovat 19th and
Kelly and I know you lived on the East
Coast up north by me and Jersey people
have left New York City they have left
and fanned out which means they're
potentially taking it with them so which
sectors do you open which I'm curious
about that date and then I'll let you go
sure let me say a few things first of
all this is why the White House and dr.
Debbie Burks who's coordinating the
current coronavirus response here for
the White House this is why Harris she
said if you were in New York in the last
14 days and you left there you should
self quarantine or self isolate whatever
her medical term was and she's saying
that - the people are out in their
houses in the Hamptons up in Connecticut
down in Florida wherever you've gone the
point is that you may be a carrier not
NOAA at Z seed spread so she was very
she was on top of that immediately to
answer your other question and I and
this is why I mentioned sort of New York
City because I think you have a lot of
commuters from Bergen and Essex County
New Jersey from Connecticut from
Pennsylvania who were going in and out
of New York City before they went on
virtual lockdown who didn't know this
and and that is why it was unfortunate
that there were mixed messages there
while other places like California were
locking down death so that's what yeah
no it's true and you do see I just heard
Murphy of New Jersey say it on the
governor's call and New Jersey as of
today has an emergency declaration in
place that was approved I think it's the
ninth state Paris and New Jersey is
really seeing a surge in cases overnight
over 50 or 60 percent as I understand
and a lot of those are the commuters in
and out of Manhattan to answer your
question about Easter the president is
tell is telling America that this
economy will have the great American
comeback the economy be turned back on
he used Easter as as an example but then
he came back and the press conference
said listen this is a medical crisis not
a financial crisis and I just want to
make sure people know this won't last
forever and he said we will follow the
science and data don't like use flexible
well it won't be an immediate speaking
he said he's going to follow the data
and the facts he's listening to his
health professionals water
dr. Burke's doctor Falchi Admiral jawar
they're here every day working around
the clock with us and they've done a
great job but I think also the economic
relief that's there today for people is
important also so they see the
government is helping them Kelly Anne
thank you so very much for caring and
thank you getting into the nitty-gritty
because I know you know this corridor
well and and how things spread and all
that detail appreciate it thank you